i think with everything else on top i
think it is
it's not sustainable long term sharon
hill is about to remortgage but with
another interest rate rise she's been
offered a deal costing her nearly 5 000
pounds extra per year you know the
additional cost is having to come
from
what would primarily be savings
you know mortgage bills they have to be
paid
my food bill has increased
another three to four hundred pounds a
month
but you have to put food on the table
she lives in the southwest a region with
the highest uk house price rises rents
have also gone up faster here than the
national average
the prices of rentals are sort of
approaching that of london
emily says demand outstrips supply and
as mortgage rates rise so does her rent
at the moment the cost of rent is taking
up sometimes 50 or more of my sort of
monthly
paycheck which is substantial
um and that seems to be going up every
year from the last over the last two
years around about 100 pounds a month
every year
and obviously the cost of living is
going up too so it's becoming quite
unaffordable to rent
the interest rate rise means average
monthly new mortgage repayments have
gone up 60 pounds on last month
288 pounds more a month since december
when the banks started hiking rates some
predict it could go further to 4.75
adding
611 pounds a month since december
for some the impact is immediate but
even many of those on fixed term
mortgages aren't safe 1.8 million are
estimated to elapse next year and with
rate rises expected for the foreseeable
so is the financial pain for homeowners
everywhere
first time buyers will be hardest hit
but all are looking for ways to ease the
burden most borrowers are looking to
stretch their term right up to
retirement age
up to 75 in some cases
just to bring those monthly payments
down
with government announcements on help
pending millions of households now hover
on the brink of real financial hardship
adele robinson sky news bristol